[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEL HEGG: So, I'm going to
talk about a few things today.
First, I'll talk about
what eBay ShopBot is.
I'll explain why
we don't integrate
with conversational
platforms in the typical way.
I'll explain our approach.
And then, I'll show you how
we use Google Cloud to make
this architecture possible.
I'm going to focus mostly on
kind of the overall-- you know,
the breadth of
what we built. I'm
not going to go super deep
on machine learning or AI.
I'll cover some of
that, but I'd also
recommend checking out Todd
Morell's talk from yesterday.
It was a pretty good coverage
of the basics of a bot
and the theory behind that.
So, just to give you a sense of
the scale that we operate at,
these are eBay's quarterly,
our second quarter, numbers.
We have 175 million active
eBay buyers worldwide.
We had 1.1 billion live
listings on our website.
We did $23.6 billion
in transaction volume,
and 60% of our revenue
was international.
This is powered by
thousands of services making
billions of requests per day.
My group at eBay develops
entirely new products
using the public cloud.
We do AI research
and development,
which includes natural language
processing, computer vision,
machine translation, and search.
We built the buying experience
for the Chinese market.
And what I'm talking about
today is conversational commerce
with eBay ShopBot on Google
Assistant and Facebook
Messenger.
So, we use Google Cloud
for almost everything.
Don't worry about trying
to digest this slide.
We essentially started
on Compute Engine.
We played with Cloud
Functions, but then we
decided what we wanted to kind
of formalize our deployment
and execution, and we
moved to Kubernetes.
And when you do that, it brings
along a lot of other things.
We use VPC for our networking,
Cloud load balancer,
and firewall rules,
VPN to connect
into our corporate
infrastructure DNS.
We use the big data
products, and then
we also use the management
and security products.
And we're a big consumer of
the Utility Compute products,
including Cloud Storage,
Big Table, and Pub/Sub.
So I figured it
would be easiest just
to show you a video of
what eBay ShopBot is
so you can see the
breadth of what
we built with this product.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Find me a Canon
Camera with a zoom lens.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JOEL HEGG: All right, so
the vision for eBay ShopBot
was an intelligent and
trusted personal shop
assistant that
understands your intent
and shops for and with you.
This video showed a
multi-turn, conversational AI
that was simple, fast,
and conversational.
Our AI demonstrates natural
language processing, computer
vision, and speech recognition.
It curates and highlights
the best deals for you
and shows the unique finds.
We have a size
profile that allows
us to remember your
preferences, and as you continue
to shop with us, we'll
remember what you entered
and personalize your
shopping experience for you.
And then, of course,
the end result
is an item card, where we
take you to an eBay page
where you can purchase the
item that you shopped for.
A major aspect of what
we've done here is ubiquity.
Instead of expecting
users to come
to ebay.com or our mobile
app, we go to the channels
where they already are.
If they're in Google
Assistant or if they're
in Facebook Messenger,
we want them
to be able to shop
from that interface.
We adjust conversations
based on the capabilities
of the channel and device
the user is currently in.
So if you're in your kitchen
and you have a Google Home,
you should be able to shop using
your voice from your kitchen.
We allow users to interact
seamlessly across devices,
resuming where they left off.
So going back to that example
of using your Google Home.
At some point, you might want
to actually see the results
that we provided for you.
So we can transfer the
conversation from your Google
Home to Google Assistant on
your phone for you to visualize.
So while ubiquity
was our goal, we
decided to start with
two markets first.
One is Google Assistant, which
has over 500 million devices
today, and Facebook
Messenger, which has
over 1.3 billion monthly users.
On Google Assistant, you
create an action to personalize
the interface as a developer.
They have over 1
million actions today.
On Facebook Messenger,
there are over 300,000 bots.
So now, I'll jump into
the technical details.
I'll explain what a
conversational platform
normally looks like and how
you would interact with it,
and then I'll talk about
why we didn't do it
in the typical way.
So, for any conversational
platform you integrate with,
this is kind of the
diagram that you
would want to build towards.
On the left, you have the user's
input device, like their phone.
It could be Google Assistant,
where they might input speech.
It could be Facebook Messenger,
where you upload an image.
And then, that's received by
the conversational platform.
That's converted
into a request that's
sent to the custom WebHook
that you create as a developer.
You would, of course, want to
validate that that request came
from the platform.
Then, you would
formulate a response
and then send back the response
synchronously or asynchronously
to the platform.
In the case of
Facebook Messenger,
they have a model that's
completely asynchronous.
With Google Assistant,
you have five seconds
to respond to the
incoming request.
And then, finally, when
the conversational platform
receives the response
from your WebHook,
it routes the
output to the user.
So this is Google's
suggested variant
of this approach for
Google Assistant.
Similar to what happened
in the last diagram,
you have the input
device on the left.
On the right, you
have your WebHook,
which they use Cloud Functions
for in all their samples.
Actions on Google is the
name of their platform
that you would develop against.
And what's different
here is in the middle,
they have Dialogflow, which is
a natural language processing
tool that they've built.
In this example, the
user might say, ask eBay
what my iPhone is worth.
This will be send from Actions
on Google to Dialogflow.
It will do the natural
language processing
and determine that the
intent of this request
was a what it's worth
request and the parameters
included a product parameter
with the value of iPhone X.
So we actually did start with
Dialogflow for Google Home.
We found it to be pretty
good for rapid prototyping,
and it helps you get going
in just a few minutes
with a working integration.
We built what I just
described in the last page,
or what its workflow,
in about five days.
And we actually
were able to demo
at the keynote at this
conference last year.
But as we went further
on in the integration,
we felt like we kind of outgrew
that workflow at some point.
The first issue was it was
challenging to scale up
development for our team.
Their tool is a kind of a
point-and-click website,
and it didn't, at the time, have
environment support or revision
control, all the kind of tools
that you, as a developer,
are normally used to having.
And so we had kind of
a medium-sized team,
and beyond a few
developers, it became
kind of challenging
to work with this.
There is a limited set of
conversational platform
integrations.
So going back to
our original goal
of being ubiquitous, what
you see there on the right
is the logos from their
website of all the platforms
they support.
And there are actually a lot
more conversational platforms
in the world than that.
Our original integration was
based on a few key categories
where we imported our
catalog into Dialogflow
so it could do
the national image
processing based on our items.
In reality, our entire catalog
has 1.1 billion listings.
It was just way too
much to actually import
into their systems.
And then we had
a requirement for
a dynamic, multi-turn dialog.
Dialogflow is kind of
built for more static kind
of closed,
retrieval-based systems.
And then, finally,
we are a big company.
We actually do have
in-house AI expertise,
and so we didn't
feel like we needed
kind of a more basic tool.
We wanted to be able
to do something more
advanced with our AI and NLU.
So not to pick on
Dialogflow, but finding
the right off-the-shelf
platform in this space
is an ongoing struggle.
Bot frameworks are in a
constant state of flux.
So similar to
Dialogflow, there's
a product called Wit.ai
that was bought by Facebook.
And now, if you go
to their website,
it's almost all geared
towards Facebook Messenger.
It's not really considered to be
a general purpose tool anymore,
even though you probably
could use it that way.
Vendor lock-in and
upselling are common.
So if you were to look
at Skype a few years ago,
they had a bot API.
And if you integrated with it,
within a little bit of time,
you had to upgrade to the
Microsoft bot framework.
That went through
a few revisions.
Now it's called the
Azure Bot Service,
and that's been used to also
upsell people on Microsoft
Cognitive Services.
So you might do a
simple free integration,
and within a couple
years, you might actually
have to pay real money
to keep it alive.
So this has driven us, over
time, to build abstractions
over these
conversational platforms
and abstract away the
platform-specific details
into just a kind
of closed area so
that we're not impacted by this
flux from these third parties.
And then, the other part
of the original diagram
I showed that Google recommended
was the use of Cloud Functions.
So when we originally
looked at this,
we ran into a few
issues that made
it kind of a non-option for us.
One were language limitations.
Our WebHook was written in
Scala, and it required Node.js.
There was an issue with not
having raw requests access.
For Facebook Messenger,
the entire security story
is based on getting
the raw requests,
computing the hash on it,
comparing it to a header
that they send you.
Without that support, they were
parsing the JSON, stripping out
whitespace, and you
could never get back
to the original request
and actually validate
that it was secure.
There was no SLA,
so we saw issues
with uneven response
times when we were
trying to use Cloud Functions.
And then there was no virtual
private cloud support,
which was an issue
for us, because we're
using Kubernetes with VPC.
And in order to access
our back-end services,
we need to be able to
get through the VPC.
Otherwise, we'd have to
expose our services publicly.
So this was my site I
had up until last night,
when I read the news that
Cloud Function's now GA,
and they pretty much
addressed all these issues.
So we might actually
need to re-evaluate it.
One, they added Python
support for languages.
They added container support.
So I don't know what
that means, but I
think it means that you can
have a normal Docker image
and run that inside
Cloud Functions.
They have raw
requests access now.
They have SLA.
They have VPC support.
They even allow you to run
Cloud Functions inside your GKE
environment.
So definitely worth
re-evaluating.
So let me dig into our approach.
This is our architecture
at a high level.
And I'll briefly go
over each of the areas,
but I'll dig into them later.
On the left, we have
a user's input device.
They might interact with
actions on Google or Facebook
Messenger.
The request is
sent to our WebHook
through a Google
global load balancer.
We'll immediately try
and identify the user
by looking up in our own
internal identity service.
From there, we'll
send the request
to our AI subsystem, which
will process the request
and generate a response.
Along the way, we'll
use reliable messaging
that we built to make sure
that the request is handled
and the response is delivered.
We record the requested
response in our chat history,
and we also do tracking
through Cloud Pub/Sub.
If the user uploaded a
media, like an image,
we'll write the media
to Cloud Storage.
And we also have a service
for doing notifications
so that we can send
requests or send messages
to the user proactively.
So this is our AI
subsystem, which is
the brains behind eBay ShopBot.
We have a custom NLU for
understanding language.
We have a Knowledge
Graph, which helps
us understand the relationships
between the things
the user is asking about.
We have a dialog manager, which
takes the output of those two
services and combines
it with the content
that we provide to formulate
the response for the user.
And then this
dialog manager will
use an AI memory to
remember what the user said
between conversational turns.
So, going into our natural
language understanding area
a little more, it transforms
natural language text
into a formal, machine-readable
representation.
So it handles parsing.
It'll take a string,
break it up into words,
identify nouns and verbs,
and add other structure
to the original input text.
It does intent
detection to determine
what was the key thing
the user is trying to do.
And then it extracts
any entities
that it can find in the text.
So, basically, parameters
to the original intent.
So the example I have
here is, my husband
needs some new black
leather dress shoes,
but I want to spend
less than $80.
What do you have?
So our NLU will go
through this, and it
does a bunch of things I
won't go into completely.
But the key thing is it
identifies the intent.
So needs and what
do you have tells it
that this is a shopping intent.
It identifies, also,
entities, including
gender, item condition, color,
product, and price range.
And then, what you
see there on the top
is it did spelling correction.
So husband was
spelled incorrectly,
so it corrected
that before it tried
to do the entity extraction.
This is something
we've had for a while.
Dialogflow, I think,
just announced
that they added support
for this yesterday.
And then, on the right, we have
some basic sentiment analysis
that we do.
So that emoji tells us something
about the user's state of mind,
and we can possibly tailor
the response based on that.
This runs in Kubernetes.
We have a variety of
machine-learned models
that we store in GCS.
And when the machine
starts up, it
loads them into persistent
SSD-backed volumes.
We have a Knowledge Graph that
is a probabilistic inference
graph of eBay user
behavioral data.
It allows us to infer
a shopping funnel,
so if the user said shoes, we
can narrow down the aspects
to just things that
are relevant to shoes.
It runs with Apache
Airflow to pull data out
of eBay, Wikidata,
Wikipedia, and that
is handled by Cloud Dataproc--
which is Google's Spark
implementation-- and loads this
into a Neo4j graph database.
At this point, we have
over 500 million nodes
and 20 billion edges.
So it requires a large amount
of CPU in memory to run this.
But we also use persistent
SST-backed volumes, as well.
And we use staple sets
so that as we deploy,
it doesn't have to reload all
that data onto the machine.
So this is an example of what
our Knowledge Graph looks like,
just so you can
understand more about it.
On the left, let's say
the user said shoes.
We know, usually,
what their gender
is, especially on
Facebook messenger,
where they have a
profile where you
can load information some basic
information about the user.
So we can skip right to the
next level question, which
in the case of a male, this
graph is saying that there
is a higher chance that
he cares about color
as his next question than brand.
So we can ask him, which
color do you prefer--
red or blue?
If it's a female, we would go
right to the brand question
and ask, do you
prefer Coach or Aldo?
Our AI memory maintains memory
across conversational turns.
It is our dialogue
state, and it also
keeps track of expected
future responses
if we are expecting more
input from the user.
So going back to the flux
that you see sometimes
when you're dealing with
conversational platforms,
this is one area
where you might want
to build your own AI memory.
Google's system provides a
dialog state object that you
can use on their system.
Something like Microsoft
Bot Framework had this,
and they took it away.
So if you're going to integrate
with something like Cortana
through Microsoft
Bot Framework, you'd
have to build this
sort of system anyway.
So you might as well
use it everywhere.
It uses Big Table, and it's
keyed on a conversation
ID, which is the ID that
the conversational platform
provides to us for each
turn of the conversation.
And then what we store
is the serialized version
of our dialog manager's
in-memory context.
So as we go through each
turn of the conversation,
we will load this context out of
our AI memory, we'll update it,
and then we'll write it
back out to Big Table.
Our dialog manager
manages the dialog flows.
The content behind
it is maintained
by editors and
designers, and this
is the voice of eBay ShopBot.
It leverages and
updates our AI memory.
And it looks at the NLU output,
AI memory, and the Knowledge
Graph to generate
further responses.
So this can lead to
another question,
or it can produce the results.
So I'm going to jump into
our WebHook and AI subsystem
interaction.
So our conversational
WebHook is built
in Node.js express TypeScript.
It currently lives in
Kubernetes, as I said,
but we could possibly port
this to Cloud Functions
in the future.
We built that as a single
service with one router,
essentially, per
conversational platform
that we integrate with.
We could split into
separate microservices
later on if we wanted to.
And the philosophy is
for this to basically
be a translation
mechanism between
the third-party
conversational platform
and our own internal
request response format
that we call Fabric API.
So this is what it looks like.
It's our internal model
of a conversational event.
And we call it Fabric because
we picture our experience being
on an ecosystem of
channels that we
want the bot to weave through.
We recently built this as a
REST JSON base interaction,
but we wanted to have a concrete
interface to build against.
We also wanted to
have client generation
for the various languages
that we integrate with.
So we defined this interface
using protocol buffers.
And I'll go into the areas
there, which are basically
a subset of the things that we
built for this, for the fabric
interface.
Event is the top-level
type, and it encapsulates
a lot of things you would
see across conversational
platforms-- so
sender, recipient,
conversation for
maintaining context
across conversational turns.
We encode capabilities that
might come from the request.
And then we break
down the event type
into either a
message, a post back,
which is essentially
a button click.
And then we can differentiate
between new users
and returning users
who are starting
a new conversation with us.
Our message type allows us to
handle both speech and text.
It allows the user
to upload media,
including images,
audio, video, and files.
It has a schedule attribute that
allows us to basically delay
messages so that we can kind
of provide pauses in the user
interaction.
We also have a typing
indicator in there,
as well, that makes it look
like the bot is thinking.
We have a card type that's
kind of a generic card
that we can use to
fill in with any items,
but usually we use it
for an eBay product.
So we put in there the title, a
price, a description, an image,
and buttons that you'd
use to interact with it.
Going back to the
message, we have
a carousel, which is a
horizontally scrolling
set of cards.
And we have a
ListTemplate, which
is a vertical version
of the same thing.
So one of the key things here
is modeling channel and device
capabilities.
So we want to able to
adapt the responses
to the channel and device.
So we have static config
based on the channel.
So, for example, what
you see here on the right
is Google Assistant
showing a vertical list.
On Google Assistant, this
can handle up to 30 items.
On Facebook Messenger,
their vertical list
can handle four items.
So when we're
integrating with this,
we want to be able to factor
in the different capabilities
of the different channels.
We also have dynamic config
based on the incoming request.
And this is especially
important on Google Assistant,
where you can have a Google
Home that's purely voice based.
Or you can have a Google
Assistant on your phone
that has a screen interaction.
So we need to be able to factor
in the two types of voice
and screen-based interactions.
NVIDIA Shield is
one product that
has Google Assistant
running on it,
but they didn't add
a web browser yet,
so we can have the user linked
to ebay.com, for example.
So we need to factor in all
these different capabilities
when we format our response.
When we do that,
though, we want to avoid
having channel-specific
logic, because we're
trying to create a
bot that has kind
of a consistent voice across
these different channels.
We want to be able to reuse that
content across those channels
without having logic
that says if Messenger
or if Actions on Google.
We want to be able
to say, basically,
in terms of
capabilities, this is
what you would show that
would optimize experience
for this device the user has.
So just to kind of
drive that home,
this is an example of what that
looks like on Actions on Google
and Facebook Messenger.
These are the basic request
payloads that you would get.
In both cases, the
user said, hello world.
And we would translate that
into a single Fabric request,
and it looks almost
identical between the two.
We include the user ID, which
is our internal user ID.
We record the channel ID, and
we take the conversation ID
that the conversational
platform gave us
and add that here, as well.
We add capabilities.
And then, finally,
in our message list,
we include the original
hello world text message.
The response is pretty
much the same thing.
In this case, our AI responded
with, you said, hello world.
And we have channel-specific
code in our WebHook hook
that can translate the Fabric
response into either Actions
on Google or Facebook Messenger.
And what you see there is
what that looks like on each
of those platforms.
So at this point, supporting
additional channels
has become more of
a business decision
than an engineering one.
We have a common back end
shared by all channels.
And we just have to create
new express router in our app
and set the endpoint for that
in our compositional platform.
The biggest challenge is then
mapping the external request
and response format
into our Fabric API
and accounting for the
unique capabilities
that that channel might have.
We've already validated
this approach.
So beyond Google
Assistant and Messenger,
we've done this integration with
Cortana and Skype, SMS, Slack.
And we've gotten
something basic working
that we know we could easily
scale out if we chose to take
our business in that direction.
So I'll go into some of
the supporting systems now.
These are not major
systems or major components
of what we built.
But I think it's
interesting to look at them,
because they were built heavily
leveraging GCP.
And it's the sort
of thing it would
take a lot more work
to build off GCP,
like on a traditional platform.
So we built our chat
history in Big Table,
and we want to archive
incoming and outgoing messages.
So some use cases include
internal dashboards
to visualize conversations,
analytics, retraining our AI
models, and hand over
to the human operator.
We basically are
just trying to record
a JSON serialized
version of the message.
We include some metadata.
We have a version attribute
that allows us to know
how to parse that message.
We include the channel,
and then we include a send
from user value
to basically know
if it was a request or response
that we're recording here.
The key thing here, if you
spend any time at Big Table,
is on the key design.
And this kind of aligns with
Big Table's best practice
for how to build a key.
But we want to be able to
retrieve based on a user ID,
so that's the first
component of our key.
Then, we also want to be able to
make sure that the messages are
in order according to the
time that the user interacted
with our bot.
So we use a timestamp.
We wanted to be able to get
those most recent first,
so we reverse the timestamp.
And then we use a
random number, in case
there are multiple
concurrent writers.
We don't want them to
overwrite each other.
And then if we're recording
multiple messages at once,
we have a batch ID that's
sequential for that batch.
So it all kind of comes
together and gives us
one, easy to interact with,
lightweight chat history
system.
We actually built a reliable
busing system in Big Table.
So the thing here is
we want to make sure
that every input from
the user gets a response.
If something goes wrong in our
back end and we drop a request,
it looks really bad.
It essentially looks
like the bot is just not
functioning very well.
It's low quality.
It also aligns with Facebook
Messenger's interaction
with WebHooks, which is
they'll send you a request,
and they expect you to
return a 200 response.
And if you don't, they'll
retry it again in 20 seconds.
If you return too
many failures, they'll
disable your bot altogether.
So no matter what
happens, we want
to be able to return a 200.
So the system we built takes
a request from Messenger,
and we immediately
write it to Big Table.
Each user has their own
queue, which is represented
by a row in Big Table.
And the message is
written to a column
with a sequential
monotonically increasing ID.
We'll try and send the
message, if we can, right away.
But if something goes wrong,
a worker will scan the table.
It will pick up the row that
still has outstanding messages.
It will automatically
try and lease the row,
and then it'll send the
messages one by one.
After all the
columns are deleted,
it will release the lease,
and then all the messages
should be sent at that point.
So this ensures ordered
at least once delivery.
We do have some edge cases
where it could possibly
result in duplicates,
but we figured
that was better than
having no responses at all.
And this is something we
built over a year ago.
We haven't had any
problems with it, really.
You have Big Table issues
that are within their SLA,
so we have blips here and there.
It hasn't really impacted users,
and every time we've had one
of these blips, it's
recovered on its own .
So conversational platforms
will deliver media
in different ways.
On the right, you see
an image being uploaded
from Facebook Messenger.
And when that's
sent to our service,
it's in the form of
a short-lived URL.
And other platforms
might deliver this media
in different ways.
So we want to
extract those details
from our back-end services.
So at the edge, in our WebHook,
we record any uploaded media
into GCS.
And then the GCS key is what
we pass around to our back end.
Once again, it's something
that just works for us.
It was very fast for
us to implement this,
and we haven't had to think
about it since we launched.
We built our notification
system with Cloud Data Store.
So this is what proactively
sends messages to users.
We handle package tracking
events, deals, Editors' Picks,
and marketing campaigns.
User descriptions are
stored in Datastore.
So the user will subscribe or
unsubscribe to a notification
through their
conversational interface.
It will be sent to our
notification service, which
records that in the
notifications DB.
We have Quartz cron jobs
that run periodically
to check to see if any
notifications need to be sent.
It will receive events from eBay
to know when package tracking
updates happened.
And we also call into
our deals API to look up
any new deals for the users.
When this notification system
runs, is invoked by Quartz,
we get a transaction
to essentially lock
the processing of notifications
to a single worker.
And this is one area we
actually might want to revisit
our decision to use Data Store.
We used it, at the time,
because it was new,
and we wanted to see
how it performed.
And we've run into rate-limiting
issues with it time and again.
So probably, what
we would do instead
is use a traditional relational
database or Cloud SQL
or something else like that.
We built our analytics
system on GCP.
And what you see here is
actually pretty standard.
Our service will track requests
and responses in Cloud Pub/Sub.
We have Cloud Dataflow that does
a stream process of any events,
and it persists the
results into Cloud Storage.
What you see on the right
is a Data Studio dashboard.
It's not ours.
It's just a sample, just to get
an idea of what it looks like.
And when the user
loads the dashboard,
it goes through BigQuery
to load the external data
from Cloud Storage, summarize
it, and then present it
to the user.
So, tying this all
together, I'm going
to show a video of Google
Assistant in action.
And I didn't go into
localization or multi-region
support, but just
a heads up, this
is done from the viewpoint
of an Australian user.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Ask eBay to find
me a Kate Spade bag.
- OK, getting eBay.
Got it.
Looking for a
color that's black,
brown, or something else?
- Black.
- Great.
Do you want a style that's
shoulder bag, messenger
and cross-body,
or something else?
- Shoulder bag.
- I looked through
seven options on eBay,
and the best deal
on this item is $95.
I have more info on
this deal for you.
Is it OK if I send
it to your phone?
- Yes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JOEL HEGG: OK, so
just to summarize,
what you saw there
was a few things
that I talked about in action.
We showed our AI.
So when the user says, ask
eBay for a Kate Spade bag,
our NLU will try and
parse that input.
It will go to our
Knowledge Graph
and try and find additional
attributes about Kate Spade
bags, so including
color and style.
It uses our Dialogue
Manager to process
the output of the NLU
and the Knowledge Graph
and then takes the content that
it has internally and formats
responses.
It uses the AI memory
so that it remembers,
across these three turns,
what the user inputted.
And then, finally,
it returns results.
We use the Fabric API
so that we can translate
from the conversational
platform, Google Assistant's
request response
format, into the format
that our AI
understands internally.
Then, we factor in channel
and device capabilities.
So the initial interaction
was through Google Home,
and it's a completely
voice-based interface.
And we had to tailor the
response with the expectation
that the user didn't
have a screen to look at.
So at the very end, when we
had results to present them,
we asked them, do they want to
transfer this conversation over
to their phone on
Google Assistant?
And that's what happened there.
We loaded the final
results of our AI memory.
And when the user came
in from their phone,
we presented them with an ID
card showing them the results.
So, in summary, eBay ShopBot
is an intelligent and trusted
personal shopping
assistant available today
for Google Assistant
and Facebook Messenger.
We ran into issues that caused
us to not use Dialogflow
or the traditional
way you'd integrate
with a conversational platform.
We built our own AI stack.
And we have a request
response format
that we translate external
formats into so we can handle
them in a platform-neutral way.
We built this on
Google Cloud to help
made this entire
architecture possible.
All right, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]